We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David.
Here's a funny voicemail.
I get that this is a joke,
but there's actually something
very serious in it. Take a listen.
Hey, David. Tim from Chicago here. So Joe
Biden keeps talking about unity and all that.
I mean, unity would be really nice, but, you
know who's going to pay for it, right? You know,
he just took office and the deficit is
already at twenty seven trillion dollars.
Right. Who's going to pay for all of humanity?
Yeah. Now, to be clear, the deficit isn't 27
trillion. It's the debt. And the debt is
also not 27 trillion. It's 23 trillion. So
important details. The debt is 23 trillion.
But the caller makes a good point, which is,
does Biden get blamed for the 400000 coronavirus
deaths starting today by right wing media?
Does Biden get blamed for the deficit that
Trump exploded starting today? And obviously,
you and I realized that after being in office
24 hours, those things are not yet your fault
or responsibility, but the right is going to
go with that. Sean Hannity already doing a
segment last night saying, you know, why isn't
Biden doing more on covid? They said they were
going to do covid, covid, covid on day one.
He hasn't done that much. That was a broadcast
nine hours after Joe Biden had been sworn in.
So I know the caller's kidding, but they aren't
kidding. They're really going to start doing that.
And this is why, again, if there's Republican
infighting that distracts them, it's only good
for Joe Biden's ability to get things done.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the Bernie Sanders Mittens
meme that has exploded since the inauguration.
We are going to talk about North Carolina okaying
a ban on hairstyle discrimination. Very
interesting. And we will also talk about
men leaving college faster
than women during the pandemic.
All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a
member at Join Pakman Dotcom.